hello is Kennedy for reason TV District
of Columbia councilman Marion Barry who
used to be the mayor of Washington DC
his made some outrageous comments lately
that have really upset certain racial
and ethnic groups here in our nation's
capital let's take a listen and do some
about these agents coming in open up
business these are dirty shops and
getting a day out ago now to say that
right now you know but we need half an
American business people to be able to
take that place you've got a really high
profile and and people really like you
and they want to like you I want to like
you I really do
I come to DC I don't live here but I
love your town why I gotta get all
racial with the businesses when racial
you to Asians in the dirty shop that's
not racial how is that not racial I'm
not gonna go to if you don't understand
it well I would like to understand it so
tell me there's a cultural difference
between a number of ethnic groups yeah
what the Hispanics or well as Asian was
a white people when there is a cultural
difference because of our socialization
because of segregation discrimination
all this adds to it and affects every
aspect of our life I understand like I
don't want to go to a dirty restaurant
the way I got to bring Asian into it
because of fact is that 95% of the
carryout you would eat I want to manage
by Asians so so I'm finished with that
[Music]